Marijuana is one of the most popular drugs for those who drink alcohol, but are there specific benefits
Or risks when taking them together what happens to your body and brain when you're drunk and stoned at the same time?
Alcohol affects your central nervous system by changing how your neurons communicate it suppresses the excitatory
neurotransmitter glutamate and increases the inhibitory
Neurotransmitter Gaba which causes information flow to become slow making you feel less perceive less and remember less
Weed on the other hand contains ThC which acts on the brains Cannabinoid receptors and causes some neurons in the brain to continually fire
Removing their normal refractory period Making your imagination and thoughts magnify
But because both alcohol and weed inhibit glutamate
Transmission a key part of your learning process [their] combined use is linked to poor memory [a] study using rats found that their ability to
recognize
Objects was severely impaired when they were drunk and high of course
Consuming both will make you feel lit and studies show that even after taking two shots the ThC levels in participants blood plasma
Doubled compared to those who were stoned, but consumed a placebo drink meaning alcohol makes you more high
Participants also felt the effects of weed more quickly and reported a better high with a better mood and other euphoric effects
Researchers believe [that] this is due to vasodilation
alcohol causes smooth muscle cells in your arteries to relax
widening of the blood vessels and an increased blood flow all of which allows more thc to cross your alveolar Sac a part of the
lung where gas Exchange occurs with the blood
Ultimately the alcohol is increasing ThC absorption other research has found that smoking dope may even reduce the damage alcohol dez on your liver
When you drink ethanol is metabolized by the enzyme cytochrome
P450 2e1 but after excessive drinking this process causes oxidative stress making cells in the liver become fatty known as steatosis
Cannabidiol [a] chemical component of marijuana was found to inhibit the cycle that causes this oxidative stress on your liver protecting it from damage
But before this becomes your go-to party Duo consider that marijuana prevents vomiting
It's one of the reasons medical marijuana is prescribed to chemotherapy patients to help ease their nausea, but in the case of alcohol poisoning
Vomiting is the body's way to remove excess alcohol
so being unable to vomit poses
serious health risks
curious how other drugs affect your body and brain check out our drug video playlist which explains even more from the effects of shrooms to
cocaine and even coffee and subscribe [for] more weekly science videos
Bye!